a man who brought so much laughter to so
many in the end it appears Robin
Williams couldn't conquer the darkness
that overwhelmed him the star was
pronounced dead at his home in
California
police say would appear to be suicide by
asphyxia his publicist said he'd been
suffering severe depression of late the
loss of one of the world's most
recognizable stars also the loss of a
husband and father in a statement his
wife said this morning I lost my husband
and my best friend while the world lost
one of its most beloved artists and
beautiful human beings I am utterly
heartbroken as he is remembered it is
our hope the focus will not be on Robins
death but on the countless moments of
joy and laughter he gave to millions
they began with his role as an alien in
Mork and Mindy
through a stand-up comedy career and one
in movies that showed his versatility
from mrs. Doubtfire mrs. Doubtfire well
I look forward to meeting you
oh me too Good Will Hunting different
from also girls I've been me so call her
up from you what this girl's perfect
right now I don't ruin that maybe you're
perfect right now maybe you don't want
to ruin that
but I think that's a super philosophy
well that way you can go through your
entire life without ever having to
really know anybody who treated his
Oscar win for that in a traditionally
manic way there were iconic movie
moments this is not a test
this is rock and roll time to rocket
from the Delta to the DMZ and
performances that now take on a renewed
poignancy if you're that depressed reach
out to someone and remember suicide is a
permanent solution to temporary problems
he'd always been open about his
struggles with alcohol and drugs saying
this after one spell in rehab I'm doing
great I want to thank the millions and
the thousands and and even the people
who just have come up in persons and
thank them for all the support it's been
loving it's been wonderful to know I'm
not alone and that's the main thing when
you come out of rehab you know that then
you got a big child he'd recently
returned for more treatment the result
friends said of working too hard as the
tributes continue to mount those who
worked with him struggled to find the
words
he made us laugh deep down in our hearts
in our minds every part of our bodies
made us laugh silly laugh and it made us
laugh very very very very complex
because we're so intelligent and the
shock goes beyond the entertainment
industry Williams had devoted himself to
charity work traveling to entertain US
troops overseas it was that that
prompted President Obama to call him one
of a kind a man who made us laugh and
made us cry he said and ended up
touching every element of the human
spirit